Speaker 1: . The Republican Civil War
is continuing to ramp up Donald Trump,
completely, completely losing it and asking
for Mitch McConnell to be removed immediately
as the Senate minority leader. And it is a tale
of contrasts in the United States in the last two
months. On the one hand, the Biden administration,
with the most stunning one, 80, a seemingly dying
presidency two and a half months ago. The
number of Biden accomplishments is incredible.
We talked about it earlier. And on the
other hand, look at what is happening
in the American right wing. Donald Trump posting
on his platform Truth Social. Just hours ago,
the Democrats have Mitch McConnell
and his lovely wife, Elaine Coco Chow,
over a barrel. He and she will never be prosecuted
as per the last paragraphs of this story.
As long as he continues to give the radical
left the trillions and trillions of dollars
that they constantly demand. He was afraid to
use the debt ceiling card in order to stop the
most expensive waste of money in our country's
history. He'll be spent on the Green New Deal,
which will only cause one thing a depression. And
then Donald Trump posting a statement. By the way,
Elaine Coco Chao. That's Trump's former secretary
of transportation. Now just attacking her,
ridiculing her, and then Donald Trump putting
out the following statement where he says much
of the same things and then adds, These
expenditures are something our country can
never recover from. Mitch McConnell is not
an opposition leader. He is a pawn for the
Democrats to get whatever they want. He is afraid
of them and will not do what has to be done.
A new Republican leader in the Senate should
be picked immediately. Listen. I welcome this.
I welcome this Republican infighting. It can
only help the odds improve for Democrats in the
House and the Senate. Now it's still bad in the
House. Democrats will almost certainly lose the
House based on the numbers as of today. If those
numbers shift between now and November, we will
see that and I will let you know. But I welcome
this completely and totally wholeheartedly. I
hope that Donald Trump continues to push this. I
can't imagine or imagine a better in fight before
the midterms. Then, should we completely
get rid of and push out Mitch McConnell,
one of the most longstanding and powerful
Republicans when there is a fight between.
Listen, I like Adam Kinzinger, okay? But he's
not like the most well-known Republican. He's not
the most powerful Republican. It's great that he
came out against Trump. I still disagree with him
on most policy. Fine. We're talking about Mitch
McConnell here. And the growing fight between the
MAGA wing and the sort of establishment wing of
the Republican Party is absolutely fantastic. And
one of the things that could be particularly good
about this is that most congressional Republicans
and I mean House and Senate are going to stand
behind Mitch McConnell, but they also aren't
likely to publicly oppose Donald Trump. And
as long as Trump doesn't come out and say, you
have to swear allegiance to me, you have to swear
loyalty to me. As long as Trump doesn't do that,
they can probably get away with what is an absurd,
wishy washy position at the end of the day, which
is, well, we stand behind Mitch McConnell, but we
also support Trump if he's the nominee or whatever
the dream scenario will be. Trump actually
demands that more and more Republicans
swear some kind of oath of loyalty to Trump
and or disavow Mitch McConnell publicly, and
it will get really ugly really quickly. Democrats
should encourage this and it is a beautiful thing.